Pessoal esse fato vai fazer você mudar
sua opinião sobre Anita nos últimos
tempos todos enfrentamos o inimigo
invisível a moléstia de 2019 mudou
nossas vidas mas a ciência seguiu
avançando Anita está ganhando destaque
ela age diretamente na enzima que produz
a proteína S essencial pro vírus atacar
nossas células mas não para por aí ela
também reduz energia dentro das células
infectadas atrasando a replicação de
muitos vírus não só o de 2019 e and a
sua expansão de vários tipos de vírus
diferente Além disso Aita estimula
interfo nosso defensor natural
fortalecendo nosso sistema imunológico
contra diversas ameaças virais ela
também reduz a produção de telina 6 uma
citocina ligada a inflamação pulmonar
grave nos casos do vírus de 2019 Anita
um aliado que trá esperança para dias
melhores protegendo vidas e fortalecendo
a verdadeira ciência